One last thing about
background subtraction.
These days there are special
kinds of cameras,
that instead of just giving us an RGB
value, they give us, RGB and D, depth.
So you're familiar with the, the
Microsoft Kinect, because unless you're
living under a rock,
you know about the Microsoft Kinect.
That's not a rock as in a Iran,
it's a rock as in granite.
So anyway RGB-D cameras, you can
then do background in depth, right?
So you take an image,
and the depth is fixed.
That is, the lights might turn on and
off, the sun might cause a shadow to
move by, but the background is fixed.
So, so in, in terms of its,
it's geometry.
So you can actually do background
subtraction in terms of geometry.
So you subtract on the d channel, and
that's pretty cool and,
and very powerful.